foreign
the introduction of new artificial
intelligence Technologies into schools
that enables students to auto-generate
essays has the capacity to
blow up our entire writing education
curriculum and may make us have to
rethink it from the ground up and that
might ultimately be a good thing
yeah I definitely doesn't look like it's
going anywhere particularly in education
I do believe that students will be able
to use this technology undetected to
complete assignments I think it's going
to be more increasingly more difficult
for teachers to be able to tell the
difference but that might there might be
a counter effect of that where teachers
have to get to know their students even
better because if you know your students
well you know the kind of things they
normally say when they write and
that should prevent some of the cheating
that might occur with the AI
and unfortunately the schools where
there is the worst teacher to student
ratio uh it's going to though it will be
more ripe for students to take advantage
of this technology and Rob themselves of
learning
um and so I imagine that our inner city
schools are going to be particularly
harmonize
how the AI technology will affect the
different uh students it depends
I suppose a lot on what subject they're
writing about and at what level
um so college students for example if
you're in a science writing class in
college and you're doing a sort of busy
work short answer
that your teacher's given you in a
chemistry class that's not going to be
as disruptive for the learner
um because you're already at a level of
sophistication where you understand the
content but if you're a younger writer
if you're in middle school and you're
writing a history paper
and you use AI
instead of your own mind to connect the
dots in history and make an argument
you've you've not only cheated on a
writing exercise you've also treated
yourself out of learning the history
the more easily available this is for
younger students uh the more problems
this will create
the fact that this might cause a crisis
in writing education
might ultimately be to our benefit
because writing is something that we
just don't teach very well it might be a
good idea for teachers to change up the
format of their essays and to get away
from the traditional five paragraph
essay because that can become formulaic
and the AI will be able to slap that
together we may want to do
um more Innovative essay formats in
whatever that might look like in
particular classrooms and ultimately I
think that will be a good thing for
teachers because just like any
profession
we can get a little bogged down
in doing things the same way all the
time you know what teachers always have
to evolve with the technology and the
standards uh the practices in schools
always seems to lag behind a little bit
what the latest technology is and you
can always be sure the kids are going to
be one step ahead of the teachers
so there needs to be a lot of vigilance
on this